one of my favorite things on snl
is you and michael when you read each
other's jokes that the
the other person wrote um and i am
curious how much are you
actually seeing those things for the
first time on the air
uh a hundred percent i'm seeing uh all
of them for the first time
on air it's very uh it's really a pretty
terrifying moment
um it's thrilling in a way but also uh
terrifying and
i don't i don't know any other moment
like that really on a
where you're gonna be on record on live
television and not know what you're
gonna say
and you feel compelled to say whatever
you see
um and the worst moments are always the
lead up to that moment where you're in a
hallway
and you hear one of the writers say you
can't make him say that oh my god
like his life will be over they'll kill
him you know
and you hear that you but you don't know
what it is and you're like oh my god can
someone please
talk jay out of whatever that was going
to be so that's that's the the scarier
part and i'll check in with him too and
i'll be like
everything's going to be okay right and
he'll be like
this was your idea or like you you you
volunteered i was like oh god
so it's it's a it's a it's a real uh
experience